Encanto's golden child Isabela was originally
very different, she had a secret boyfriend
and got married, was a book lover like Belle,
and could grow magical potato people.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing Isabela's deleted
scenes and rejected storylines that you never
got to see!
Some spoilers ahead so take care.
One of the funniest moments in the movie is
when the magic goes wrong at Isabela's proposal
dinner.
As the family's powers misfire, Isa's true
feelings about picture-perfect Mariano sprout
up, subconsciously revealing that she doesn't
want to marry him.
However, in an earlier version of the story,
Isabela had a different boyfriend she chose
herself who she'd meet up with in secret in
the woods.
In an official deleted scene, Mirabel spots
her sister getting dragged into the forest
by a mysterious hooded character, and chases
after her thinking she's in danger.
Seeing what looks like an animal approach
Isabela, Mirabel attacks the mystery creature
until she discovers that it's actually...
Bubo Marqués.
Are you alright?
I'm fine, mi amor.
Mi amor?
Just go home.
You saw nothing.
I wish I saw nothing.
What I did see was like two baby birds feeding
each other.
Bubo was from the city so an outsider to the
Encanto, and combined with his quirky personality,
the intention was for him to have a comical,
fish-out-of-water vibe.
I'm wearing this jaguar-print coat.
Wild animals see it and they're like is that
a jaguar?
And I'm all like, yes!
And they're like, I will not mess with him.
Most predators hunt by smell.
Which is why I covered it in the urine of
several animals.
The deleted scene continued with Isabela revealing
that she planned to leave the Encanto with
Bubo, presumably to go to the city.
You're trying to leave?
The place where every person worships the
ground you walk on to go out there?
Bubo Marqués!
What is this?
Dark magic?
Bubo is the only person who has ever really
seen me.
And this moment before the barrier is restored
is our only chance to be free.
So in this version of Isabela's story, it
appears something had happened to open the
barrier that kept the Encanto separated from
the outside world.
And perhaps this was an early sign that the
family's magic was weakening.
Although there's some humour in this scene
such as Mirabel's reaction to the super-awkward
kissing, I can see why it was cut as many
of the audience might have found it as uncomfortable
to watch as Mirabel did, and many fans reacted
in horror when they saw this deleted scene.
Also, having Bubo as Isabela's love interest
would have shifted the focus of her arc away
from discovering what she wanted for herself
in her life, plus it's kind of cliché in
terms of its quirky guy and pretty girl trope
we've seen many times before.
In the end, this romantic plot for Isabela
was replaced with Isa rejecting the suitor
Abuela had lined up for her and making choices
for herself that didn't depend on a love interest.
I never wanted to marry him!
I was doing it for the family!
An alternate version of the Bubo scene can
also be found in this unused concept art of
a secret garden created by Isabela that Mirabel
wanders into.
It looks like it could have been an amusing
moment and it reminds me a lot of the lilies
scene in Disney's The Princess and the Frog.
And in another version of Isabela's secret
garden, Mirabel descended into a spiky, dark
thicket of trees with creepy faces embedded
in the wood.
And Bruno, who looked very different in earlier
stories, followed Mirabel into the spooky
area which was deliberately designed like
that by Isabela to scare people away so they
wouldn't find out about her secret boyfriend.
Bubo haters will also be shocked to discover
that Isabela was originally going to marry
him in one of Encanto's epilogues.
Clearly from the celebrations, the family
had accepted Bubo by this point;
and, given the way the bride and groom kiss
here it looks like Isa and Bubo's heavy make-out
sessions were going to be a running joke in
this version of the story.
A fun bonus in this original ending is how
it looks like it was Dolores who caught the
bridal bouquet and ended up with Mariano,
as she wanted to in the final movie as well.
Yes!
Let's get married..
Slow down.
In an alternate take on the story, Isabela
also loved to read and she created giant hydrangeas
in her room that she and Bubo would lie on,
giving a feeling of them floating on a cloud.
In this story, the clouds represented Isabela's
desire to be free and true to herself, while
at the same time she was "still trapped in
her room".
This whole shot is stunning, from the detail
of the sun on the floor to the walls made
of glass which made the room resemble a vase
for putting flowers on display, just as Abuela
put Isa on display.
And you can see Mirabel peeking into the room,
where presumably she would have caught Isa
with Bubo.
And I love this little test animation of Isabela
creating a flower seat and plant light bulb
to read her book.
I wonder if they decided against her being
a book-lover though as that on top of her
general Disney princess vibe might have made
her feel a little too reminiscent of Belle
from Beauty and the Beast.
There's a small but funny deleted moment from
just before Mirabel hugs it out with her sister,
where Isabela makes fun of Mirabel by doing
an impression of her with glasses made out
of her vines.
This would have ended up causing a full-on
fight between the two sisters.
I can see why the physical fight was cut though
as it's a little tropey and I think the scene
we got of Isabela's repressed emotions coming
through as flowers sprouting up in Mirabel's
face was funnier and more interesting as her
anger at having to be constantly perfect finally
bubbles up to the surface.
An amazing concept for Isabela which sadly
didn't make it into the movie was her ability
to create animated plant creatures, such as
these potato characters.
These living potatoes, dressed in traditional
outfits, would have populated the house and
even tended their own crops.
Leave a thumbs-up if you love these guys!
And there was an awesome deleted scene where
they helped Mirabel learn about the history
of a big battle, by re-enacting it together
with an army of magical wallpaper soldiers
created by Casita.
By the way, Casita's magical wallpaper is
another deleted concept which I'll be discussing
more in my next video, so make sure you're
subscribed and click the notification bell
on to get that video.
In another cut epilogue scene, we can see
that Isabela's door design had both books
and crossed swords on it and there would have
been a fun moment where she emerged and it
was revealed that she'd been fencing with
Bubo inside her room where they'd been "role-playing
something from a book that they had read earlier".
And at one point in the story, Isabela was
going to have a punk-rock look.
I expect this would have come at the moment
when she decided being a Señorita Perfecta
wasn't what she really wanted so transformed
her look from soft pastel shades to much bolder
colours, ending up with a splatter-paint design.
The punk-rock version of her would have hinted
at an even edgier sense about her newfound
self, but perhaps it would have been a bit
too cliché for her to go from a classic Disney
princess vibe to a full-on rebel child.
And had Bubo made it into the final cut, he
would have also been in the final frame where
one of Bruno's rats takes a picture of the
family and we get the running joke again of
Isa and Bubo smooching together.
In fact, there were even more alternate endings
that were cut from Encanto including a hilarious
post-credits scene with a capybara, plus a
surprise ending for Camilo.
Tap here to learn all about those and there's
also a link in the video description.
And if you'd like to see more gorgeous concept
art from Encanto, consider getting a copy
of The Art of Encanto book.
There's a link in the description on how you
can get it with free worldwide shipping.
So, are you a Bubo lover or hater?
And do you wish any of these Isabela deleted
scenes had been in the movie?
Let me know in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this video, do leave a thumbs-up,
I really appreciate it.
Next tap left for even more Encanto deleted
scenes including a giant Camilo transforming
into Bruno.
That'll be my next video.
Thanks for enjoying this movie with me and
hope you have a marvellous movie-loving week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!